hidden away in the tuscan hills of  northern italy this beautiful moorish  castle was built in 1605  but for more than two decades it's been  sitting empty  there are 365 rooms in the castello di  samazano  one for every day of the year  the moroccan style palatial villa is a  labyrinth of exquisitely tiled rooms  each one intricately unique  the castle was once a luxury hotel  restaurant and bar but closed its doors  in the early 1990s  it wasn't until 2013 that a local  non-profit committee was founded to help  raise awareness for the increasingly  decaying castle  they have no ownership of samatsano but  they help to arrange and promote rare  public openings  you